bonjour je suis dans une situation
extrêmement singulière
mon métier est de donner la parole aux
autres et me voilà devant vous je n'ai
jamais fait ça si je les fais si je les
accepte et c'est pour une raison et je
vais vous lire je vais commencer par
vous lire très rapidement un mail que
j'ai reçu d'un net d'un homme que j'aime
profondément que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure
il s'appelle leurs anchois chaire
sylvain comme à chaque fois c'était
encore mieux que la fois d'avant la cité
est unique
vous en avez fait une aventure humaine
particulièrement inspirante et qui ne se
répète pas il y a aussi beaucoup de
présence et de maestria personnel dans
cette aventure donc bravo du coup
laissez-moi arrosé l'arroseur j'aimerais
beaucoup que vous puissiez être l'un des
speakers de cette journée
le thème général est oxymore mais votre
toc sera libre l'expérience de la cité
sa genèse mais aussi peut-être le sens
de ce que vous y faites la diffusion
d'une culture de la réussite dans un
cadre populaire est positif
comment lui dire non donc je vais vous
raconter notre aventure notre aventure
démarre probablement moins 500 ans avant
jésus-christ dans la grèce antique avec
la création de l'agora et elle démarre
véritablement en 1989 après jésus-christ
nous sommes trois copains 3 étudiant à
la sorbonne et nous décidons de créer
cette cité de la réussite une idée
extrêmement simple réunir pendant 48
heures des personnalités du monde de la
politique de l'économie des sciences de
la culture qui viendraient librement et
directement répondre à un public qui se
composerait dans un premier temps
d'étudiant et dans un second temps
d'hommes et de femmes qui s'intéressent
au débat d'idées
c'est une femme d'origine grecque et la
nouvelle ère qui dirige cette sorbonne
et qui va nous donner son accord
et alors a coutume de dire depuis mai 68
c'est la première fois que des étudiants
auront toute l'université mais cette
fois ci ils ont eu la correction de
venir me le demander je vais rapidement
déroulées ces 25 ses 25 années 1989
notre premier invité est sans doute à
l'époque l'une des personnalités les
plus importantes d'europe voire au delà
il est le président de fiat c'est un
homme de culture il s'appelle giovanni
agnelli tous les médias de france et de
navarre souhaite la voir
il dit non à tout il nous dit oui pour
ce dialogue réel avec la jeunesse
en 1990 au lendemain de la chute du mur
de berlin c'est à l'autre chambre double
tchèque vaclav havel et tous les leaders
de l'est qui vont venir répondre aux
étudiants et leur expliquer ce qui vient
de se produire
en 1992 c'est probablement l'une de mes
plus belles anecdotes
nous invitons le shimon peres qui est à
l'époque ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'état d'israël et nous le
faisons une proposition venir dans ce
grand amphithéâtre de la sorbonne
dialoguer avec un panel de jeunes
étudiants arabes qui représenterait tous
les pays arabes
je dis bien tous les pays arabes et
notamment ceux avec lesquels israël
était en guerre
perez prend trois jours de réflexion son
cabinet nous rappelle et nous dit il est
d'accord et bien ce soir là les deux
mille personnes qui étaient dans la
salle
en 1992 s'en souviennent encore
aujourd'hui une étudiante parmi ce panel
une étudiante se lève elle se présente
elle dit monsieur je ne vais pas
m'adresser à un ministre je vais
m'adresser un homme qui pourrait être
mon grand père je suis palestinienne
pensez vous un jour que je pourrais
vivre dans mon pays
il y à un silence d'une minute qui nous
semblent des heures et ce soir là shimon
peres va dérouler pour le public présent
tout ce que seront les accords d'oslo de
l'année suivante en 1994 à la veille de
la présidentielle française
le premier ministre s'appelle edouard
balladur le maire de paris jacques
chirac
c'est une guerre terrible entre eux à
l'époque certains considèrent que
edouard balladur est d'ores et déjà élu
nous les invitons tous les deux à deux
heures d'écart probablement que les gens
qui ont assisté à ces deux rencontres
ont compris ce jour là que jacques
chirac serait et du 1996 une formidable
histoire je vous parlais de mai 68 le
retour de dany cohn bendit à la sorbonne
dans l'amphithéâtre richelieu et
l'émotion de cohn bendit qui retrouve
tant d'années après cette sorbonne a été
aussi pour nous un moment unique 1999
pour la première fois nous sortons des
murs de la sorbonne et nous allons à
marseille tout près d'ici avec notamment
jacqueline de romilly et andré chouraqui
qui vont ce soir là sur une thématique
complètement improbable la société et
ses dieux réunir plus de 1000 personnes
dans ce palais du pharo 1998 liêu dit
menuhin nous avons nous avons été juste
avant moi
nous avons compris le rôle et
l'importance de la musique
menuhin ce soir là le musicien a parlé
dans un silence assourdissant
devant une assemblée de jeunes de ce
qu'était pour lui la vieillesse 1999
l'homme qui était maire de paris en 1994
a depuis été élu président de la
république
il nous avait fait une promesse si je
suis élu je reviendrai il a fait un
débat qui a duré deux heures et demie de
dialogue direct avec la jeunesse en 2000
nous avons choisi avec l'équipe de
maîtrise elle parce qu il y incarne
l'une des valeurs que nous voulons
porter depuis tant d'années qui est
celle de la transmission en 2002 deux
hommes l'un derrière l'autre exactement
l'un derrière l'autre vont donner à
toute cette jeunesse probablement
l'envié d'entreprendre françois pinault
d'une part jean luc lagardère d'autre
part en 2004 elle n'est pas patronne du
fmi
elle n'est pas encore ministre des
finances elle est avocate elle vient
chez nous et je crois je crois que nous
avons peut-être déclenché chez elle une
certaine volonté 2006 de nouveau une
campagne présidentielle ségolène royal
et nicolas sarkozy vont débattre pas
ensemble l'un derrière l'autre et notre
idée aussi c'est de montrer que ces
lieux de débat réel de confrontation
peuvent s'opérer dans un climat
extrêmement apaisée en 2008
notre thème et l'engagement et nous
sommes allés chercher deux femmes
tellement différente qui ont toutes les
deux un certain nombre d'engagements
qu'elles sont venez développer la reine
rania de jordanie d'une part sharon
stone d'autre part en 2010 je dois vous
confesser que c'était un rêve que
j'avais depuis très très longtemps
accueillir simone veil simone veil
venait d'être élu à l'académie française
c'est là je crois que même on vous le
raconte en une forme d'émotion c'est la
dernière apparition publique qu'elle
fera chez nous à la cité dans ce
merveilleux dialogue
cette année aussi de 2012 est marquée
par la présence dans le sang soo qui est
l'anecdote que je peux vous raconter sur
un san suu kyi
c'est le sait elle rentre sur la scène
et dieu sait si depuis vingt-cinq ans
j'ai reçu des personnalités la
standing-ovation qu'elle a eue était
incroyable et 10 du ca eu du mal à la
faire stopper 2014 ce sera la dernière
édition avant la prochaine
nous avons mis carlos ghosn le président
de renault parce qu'à travers lui nous
tenions à vous préciser que évidemment
tout ça est possible grâce de très
nombreux partenaires partenaires qui
nous soutiennent et nous en sommes tous
émus pour une raison que toutes ces
entreprises acceptent de financer un
projet qui donne simplement l'idée du
dialogue et du débat on l'a vous l'aurez
compris dans cette première partie
voilà ce qu'est mon métier en 2000
d'aucuns nous ont dit avec l'apparition
des réseaux sociaux
ça ne marchera plus ce que vous faites
ne fonctionnera plus tous les atouts les
réseaux sociaux toutes les toutes les
nouvelles technologies vont vous
remplacer ma conviction profonde était
en 2000 c'était compliqué de la voir
c'était que ce serait exactement
l'inversé plus le virtuel se
développerait et plus le réel serait
nécessaire vous êtes face à moi au même
endroit dans un même lieu et je dirais
que cela aujourd'hui est plus que jamais
nécessaire
alors je vous disais que depuis 2000 le
troisième ingrédient évidemment et le
public
les speakers les partenaires le public
oui ce public a été de plus en plus
nombreux ça n'a pas forcément à voir
avec nous c'est cette volonté d'être
ensemble et de partager les nouvelles
technologies nous aident à amplifier
démultiplier faire savoir et nous
combinons le virtuel et le réel
et c'est pour ça que j'ai intitulé ce
taux que le virtuel meilleurs alliés du
réel parce que j'ai l'intimé conviction
que jamais le réel ne disparaîtra et
qu'il complétera le virtuel
alors au delà de nous au delà de nous
citer de la réussite bien évidemment ce
réel et de plus en plus nécessaire
l'industrie du disque s'effondre n'est
jamais les concerts jamais les tournées
non aussi bien fonctionné vous avez sur
l'image alain souchon et laurent voulzy
les dates qu'ils avaient initialement
prévus sont quasiment multiplié par deux
au-delà des concerts le spectacle vivant
vie une réussite extraordinaire
nous avons mis avec l'équipe qui a
préparé cette présentation 2-2 exemple
le puy du fou ou le cirque du soleil
mais nous ne nous aurions pu en mettre
une vingtaine tellement le spectacle
vivant les lieux de rencontres réelles
sont nécessaires au delà du spectacle
vivant
au delà de l'industrie du disque le
troisième et dernier point que je
voulais mettre en avant était la
politique
pourquoi lors de la première élection de
barack obama
d'aucuns ont dit donc en 2008 le real
est terminée toutes les campagnes se
feront sur les réseaux sociaux
bien sûr les réseaux sociaux ont joué un
rôle central mais les éléments les plus
forts et les plus fondateur resteront
ces grands meetings françois hollande au
bourget nicolas sarkozy à villepinte
ces deux hommes que nous avons reçues
considère que les moments fondateurs de
leurs campagnes sont ces moments là
pour terminer je voudrais vous parler de
deux hommes le premier joël de rosnay
nous accompagne depuis la première citée
il n'en la louper aucune
il est la quintessence de ce de ce
croisement entre le virtuel et le réel
et le deuxième homme que je veux citer
en conclusion nous ne l'avons jamais
reçu il ne viendra jamais il a dit tout
ce qui peut être imaginé est réel il
s'appelait pablo picasso
je vous remercie